après le kayak polo ou après le basket
on continue à évoquer le sport
l'ensemble des résultats c'est le 78
sport chaque lundi oui je l'évoqué en
sommaire d'émission les chocs des
lancours c'est dur au roquet ont validé
un leur ticket pour la Nationale 2 le
weekend dernier il y a 8 jours du côté
de villneu lagagaren et l'entraîneur
joueur Benjamin furand nous fait
l'amitié d'être ce soir parmi nous
bonsoir à vous vous êtes accompagné de
votre capitaine Alexis müer bonsoir à
alors une montée en National 2 vous
finissez 6e sur cette phase finale je
vous propose d'ailleurs de de jeter un
petit coup d'œil au classement
rapidement voilà c'est Cholet qui était
sûrement peut-être intouchable sur ce ce
weekend de phase finale qui qui est
champion de de de National 2 et puis
donc vous êtes 6e qualifié et donc vous
validez votre ticket pour cette
Nationale 2 c'est plutôt inespéré comme
résultat en en vue de la du début de
saison non inespéré je je dirais pas ça
mais c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas à
ce qu'on aille aussi le but c'est de se
qualifier en play-off ensuite voilà tout
le reste c'était CIT pour moi du du
bonus on était passé pas très loin l'an
dernier de de se qualifier et puis là on
s'est qualifié et on est allé au bout de
de l'histoire jusqu'à jusqu'à la montée
jusqu'à la jusqu'à la plateau finale et
donc vraiment une très très belle
réussite après inespéré je dirais pas ça
c'était c'était pas dans le programme
mais c'était c'est une bonne une bonne
surprise B et le titre était enfin cette
première place de conquise parchol était
inaccessible sur ce weekend là je dirais
pas inaccessible je dirais que voilà les
les deux les deux finalistes Cholet
villeeneuve la Garen était était
au-dessus du tournoi ça y a ça c un
contesté et alors du côté des joueurs le
capitaine est présent Alexis il y a eu
une bonne émulation qui s'est créée
justement en allant sur ces play-offs
puisque vous vous êtes qualifié dans les
dernières journées je pense que
l'émulation elle est venue avant en fait
dès l'écart on s'attendait pas à passer
en demi et dès l'écart on a senti qu'il
y avait un esprit d'équipe quelque chose
qui s'est créé en plus et voilà c'est
vraiment l'esprit d'équipe et l'entente
et l'envie qui a fait la différence et
qui nous a anné jusque là jusqu'en final
et alors cette cette montée en National
2 Benjamin vous courriez depuis
longtemps après ou voilà c'était un
objectif qui était plus prioritaire la
saison prochaine par exemple oui c'était
un objectif sur le long terme là c'est
vrai que ça fait 2 ans que je suis entré
je suis entraîneur joueur et ça arrivit
vite mais tant mieux on va essayer de se
maintier l' prochain essayer de monter
une belle équipe il y a des joueurs qui
qui ont envie de nous rejoindre et puis
j'aimerais aussi profiter de de mon
passage pour remercier d'abord les le
les g du bureau la la présidente
Christine nen Séverine boutele et Didier
boutele qui sont aussi très présents sur
le club
Carole bénévol bénévoles vraiment bénv
les gens de la mairie aussi j'aimerais
remercier qui qui font un gros boulot
pour nous et puis pour l'an prochain
s'il y a des gens qui sont intéressés
pour nous donner des sponsors nous ser
très intéressés pour monter notre projet
Alexis en tant que joueur bon benjamin
est joueur aussi mais il a plus la
casquette d'entraîneur ce soir c'est
c'est unique c'est vraiment incroyable
cette sensation voilà de de vivre une
montée ouais on en vit pas déjà des
beaucoup dans dans une vie de joueur moi
ça fait 10 ans que je suis au choc c'est
on a fait on a fait deux montées là ça
va faire la troisème c'est vrai qu'on
était monté en N1 on était redescendu
jusqu les 200 bah pour l'instant depuis
quelques années on connaît que les
descentes et que les défaites entre
guillemets donc là ça fait à peu près un
an et demi depuis l'arrivée de Benjamin
que on il y a quelque chose qui se passe
et voilà on renoue avec la victoire et
c'est vrai que l'effet de groupe secrèt
euh forcément dans la victoire on
s'entend mieux et l'entente est plus
plus plus cordiale et cetera et je
tenais à remercier au nom de l'équipe
bah le notre entraîneur forcément sans
sans lui ça aurait pas été possible donc
au nom de toute l'équipe merci merci au
coach pour cette pour cette saison ça
fait une dizaine d'années vous nous
disez que vous étiez au club que vous
êtes au club ça veut dire que vous êtes
là depuis quasiment l'origine
euh la première3 j'étais j'étais présent
ce qui fait que le club quand il a
démarré a très vite réussi à grimper les
échelons il y a eu beaucoup
d'engouements après qu'est-ce qui a
expliqué ces diff ulté la redescente et
puis le travail qu' a dû avoir derrière
pour reconnaître la victoire bah je
pense que bah déjà il y a eu il y avait
quelques bons joueurs qui voilà par
l'effet du bouche à l'oreille ont amené
d'autres d'autres joueurs donc il y
avait eu une émulsion de sur les
premières années qui ont fait qu' plein
de bons joueurs qui sont partis par la
suite et voilà et derrière ce qui manque
je pense encour c'est ce qui est en
train d'être fait en ce moment c'est des
jeunes en fait qui viennent prendre le
relais quand voilà les trentenaires on
commen déjà à être un peus vers la fin
les trentenair pendant une dizaine
d'années encore tant que je peux rouler
je roule mais bon bah vous pourrez
rouler à n'importe quel âge après mais
ce sera pas la même vitesse pas la mê V
non mais en gros voilà il y en a
beaucoup qui arrivent à la trentaine et
ce qu'il nous faut c'est des jeunes
derrière qui viennent pousser et prendre
prendre le relais quoi parce qu'on peut
pas recruter comme ça des des anciens
tous les ans c'est c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident Benjamin vous êtes un
peu l'homme providentiel alors si on
comprend bien Alexis non Paris que je
sais que vous êtes très accxé aussi sur
la formation c'est important pour vous
oui on essaie vraiment de de développer
les jeunesses on a on a des jeunes qui
ont au sein d'une ent
ont réussi à être qualifié en minim et
en et en CAD là je crois que les minim
sont en finale et les CAD on sont allés
jusqu'en demi-finale donc il y a aussi
eu un beau parcours à ce niveaaul mais
voilà on en est qu'au début là du
développement des jeunesses en tout cas
de C dans cette intention là et on
espère vraiment faire grandir et qu'il y
en a qui vont nous mettre à la retraite
bientôt et justementannée prochaine
direction la Nationale 2 qu'est-ce que
ça va impliquer en terme financier
est-ce que voilà le budget va va gonfler
petit peu comme on dit euh c'est ben oui
on on espère que la mairie et des
sponsors vont venir nous rejoindre pour
pour essayer d'avoir un budget un plus
important après les
déplacements ça reste quand même il y a
quatre poules il y a quand même beaucoup
d'équipes on a la chance en î- defance
d'avoir beaucoup d'équipes qui seront en
région parisienne euh voilà après le but
c'est vraiment de se maintenir et puis
de d'essayer vraiment de maintenir le
groupe même quand ça va être difficile
parce que là on va jouer des en gros le
niveau hein ça va être ça va être des
demi-finales ou des finales de N3 tout
tout tous les weekends donc ça va être
vraiment dur et il va falloir vraiment
que le groupe se sert les coudes même
quand ça va être quand on va peut-être
avoir deux trois des défaites vraiment
se serrer les coues pour essayer de de
continuer à avancer de et de progresser
ce qui va jouer aussi c'est que pour
reprendre une une expression de notre
coach on a été en sousnuméraire sous
numuméraire toute l'année donc manque
d'effectif en fait et là on est en train
de chercher de recruter des nouveaux
joueurs pour être en sur numuméraire
toute toute la fin de saison et ça va
faire la différence sur la N2 parce que
forcément plus de matchs des matchs plus
intenses donc des blessures plus de
fatigue donc il faut forcément derrière
un banc ça c'est indispensable qu'on
avait pas cette saison quoi et justement
recruter une montée c'est c'est avec une
montée c'est plus facile d'attirer les
joueurs et vous avez voilà beaucoup plus
de contact qui AR ou ouais il y a des
joueurs qui qui viennent taper à la
porte là on a déjà 4 C joueurs qui sont
vraiment intéressés par le projet et ces
qu C joueurs là seront très importants
l'an prochain pour notre réussite et
alors vous vous allez essayer de mettre
en place une structure un petit peu
différente par rapport à cette équipe
fagon ou ou ça va rester dans dans la
bonne tradition qui qui fait le succès
cette année euh benah on va essayer nous
on a vraiment une équipe qui a une qui
c'est construit autour d'un d'un gros
gardien et d'une bonne base défensive
donc on va quand même essayer ça de de
le conserver et puis je pense aussi ce
qui nous a fait gagner c'est que comme
disait Alexis voilà on a réussi à créer
une bande de copains qui se battent les
uns pour les autres et ça cet esprit là
on va essayer de le garder et en buvant
une bonne bière le soir après
l'entraînement je pense que ça ça crée
des gain avec modération avec modération
toujours ça crée des liens et ça fait
qu'on a qu'on a une vie de club
intéressante et qu'on est heureux d'être
ensemble et et de progresser par rapport
à ce projet là c'est curieux comment du
succès d'aller boire avec modération une
bonne bière après l'entraînement c'est
pas tous les tous les coachs disent pas
ça forcément ça CR ça crée du lien
social ça crée du lien social je dis pas
je dis pas de de boire 10 bières après
mais une petite bière ensemble je pense
que la tradition du rugby là ça ça ça
permet de important de vivre des moments
en dehors du terrain en dehors du
terrain et qu'on soit pas on n'est pas
des professionnels donc donc ce bien
vivre ensemble il nous permet aussi de
bien vivre sur le terrain d'ailleurs si
les caméramans qui viennent nous filmer
TVfil veulent participer à la fin des
match on
est écoutez ils sont en régie je pense
qu'ils ont noté voilà je je pense qu'il
s en régie apparemment voilà exactement
le message est passé pour la saison
prochaine tout de même il y a des
adversaires qui vous font qui vous font
peur malgré tout parce que ça va changer
d'univers euh il faut déjà attendre la
fin du championnat national 2 pour
savoir queles sont les équipes qui vont
descendre savoir aussi quels sont les
qui vont monter pardon et savoir aussi
quels sont les équipes qui vont
descendre de national une mais c'est sûr
que nous on est des petits poussés on
sera les dousiders donc toutes les
équipes vont faire peur l'an prochain
euh mais en se comportant en outsider en
petit poussé on est on a fini 6e du
championnat et 3 et on est monté donc on
va continuer à être les Siders les
petits poussés ou mais vous pourrait pas
toujours compter sur les fait de
surprise non plus vous serait peut-être
plus attendu cette fois-ci
ah en N2 c'est pas dit en N2 c'est pas
dit on pourra encore profiter quelques
temps puis l'année prochaine si on monte
en N1 on pourra encore faire plus pouss
en en une3 les équipes qui nous
regardaient jouer disaient ah c'est bon
il en cours on va les taper on va se
faire le GO à ver sur eux et à chaque
fois c'est nous qui sont passés donc on
va essayer de continuer comme ça très
bien on suivra ça de près la saison
prochaine et votre préparation auss à
l'intersaison merci à tous les deux
d'êtreevenu ce soir sur le plateau de TV
fil et donc à l'année prochaine merci
beaucoup et puis que des bonnes
nouvelles donc ce soir démonter en
basket démoné en r roquet on va
continuer à voir si les résultats des
autres équipes ont été aussi bons ce
weekend les résultats tout de
suite
[Musique]
ce weekend avait lieu la 4e édition
wilfri des Olympiades du vivre ensemble
à versaill un événement dédié au ris
sport les nonvalides pouvaient découvrir
notamment le basket fauteuil le tennis
de table encore le C6 foot un dernier
atelier qui a reçu la visite
prestigieuse d'Emmanuel petit l'ancien
champion du monde 98 30 hommage
d'ailleurs au joueurs de ces si foot et
espère voir le handicap progresser dans
le monde sportif on l'écoute tout de
suite
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé mais qu'est-ce
que vous voulez on
a lorsque vous êtes valide vous mettez
en situation d' handicap c'est c'est
très très compliqué c'est comme si vous
demandiez à un non valide de se mettre à
la place d'un valide c'est c'est la même
chose même
si on apprend avec l'habitude ça reste
toujours très compliqué moi ça fait 25
ans que jeis monde associatif et aussi
dans le monde de l'handicap et même si
les mentalités ont évolué il y a encore
beaucoup de chemins à faire parce que la
ségrégation la discrimination existe
tout le temps au même des différents
handicaps donc ça vous laisse présager
de ce qui peut y arriver dans la société
de tous les jours avec les valides en
football 25e et avant dernière journée
de Division d'Honneur Versailles s'est
imposé sur le terrain de blancménil on
va voir d'ailleurs les les résultats
s'affichés un but à zéro les Versaillais
sont désormais 5e de leur poule de
division d'honneur en promotion
d'honneur 20e 21e journée de la ple B
Trapp n'a laissé aucune chance au mentoi
les traapistes l'emportent 3-1 et
conforent ainsi leur 3è place au
classement avec trois points d'avance
sur colombe dans la pouse aiguille en
cours a retrouvver le goût de la
victoire face à la lanterne rouge et les
Ros score final 4-2 les 5 continois
n'avaient plus gagné depuis 2 mois
Wilfried et un match face au chînet le
24 mars dernier h football féminin chez
les femmes pour le compte de la 22e et
dernière journée de Division 2 Montini
7e se déplaçait chez le 9e temple
marvandeville mais les inontaines n'ont
pas terminer la saison par un succès
elle s'incline dans un match assez fou
54 et finissent la saison en milieu de
tableau
du tennis il n'y a pas que Roland Garros
exactement 3è journée des championnats
de France par équipe en National 3
plaisir enchaîne une deuxième victoire
consécutive en s'imposant à domicile
face à Amien 5 matchs à deux en National
4 boisarsy n'a pas fait le poids devant
le cercle féminin de Paris les les
arcisiens s'inclinent 7 matchs à 1 chez
les femmes en National 4 plaisir qui se
bat pour le maintien se déplacer à soisi
sur scène et c'est incliné de justesse
après les matchs de double 4-3 sport
collectif du baseball l'équipe de Monti
le bretonux 6e journée 6e journée he de
Division 2 Montini se déplacçait dans le
valdoise à hermont un premier match
synonyme de promenade le matin 10-0 pour
les cougard et l'après-midi les joueurs
d'arnaofo enchaînent avec un second
succès 5-4 les inimontins reprennent la
2uxème place au panère de Pessac et on
termine dernier résultat par de la boxe
la boxe thaïlandaise oui samedi soir
trappe organisé à un gala pour quatre
ceintures européennes de boxe
thaïlandaise lors du gala one versus one
dans la catégorie - 65 kg le trapiste
Abd
est devenu à 37 ans champion d'Europe il
a battu au point le Portugais Rui
brisseno chez les Espoirs le club du
chînis s'est illustré avec tro victoires
d'Alexandre Leit Mohamed Bouard et
Guillaume Baboin merci Antony on vous
retrouve lundi prochain comme chaque
semaine 18h30 pour un point complet sur
l'actualité sportive et continuez de
nous transmettre tous vos résultats
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à commenter sur
Twitter le 78 sport avec le hashtag le
78 sport tout attaché à la semaine
prochaine bonne soirée